hey legal eagles it's time to adjudicate
the matter of judge Cavanaugh versus dr.
Christine Blasi Ford alright let's think
like a lawyer like most of the country
I've been glued to the Cavanaugh Ford
hearings regardless of what side of the
aisle you stand I think it raises
important questions for our country it
also raises particularly GLE issues that
I think deserve a thorough debate so
today I'd like to give you the first
real law review of the Cavanaugh Ford
hearing from the perspective of a lawyer
this will be the first in a new series
on this channel where I try to tackle
the most important legal issues of the
day if you have a suggestion for the
next legal topic I should cover please
leave that down below and if you
disagree with me be sure to leave your
comment in the form of an objection and
by the way if you'd like to see me
critique your favorite legal TV show
like suits or a better call Saul check
out my real lawyer react series the link
for that will be down below now there
are five questions that I want to cover
today number one did judge Cavanaugh
commit legal perjury number two did he
display a judge like temperament number
three would judge Cavanaugh prevent
investigations into President Trump or
the white house number four would the
current allegations of sexual assault
hold up in court
and number five should Judge Cavanaugh
have requested an investigation by the
FBI now before we begin on a personal
note this is not meant to be a partisan
analysis I'm not gonna give you my
opinion on whether I think Judge
Cavanaugh should be elevated to the
Supreme Court based on his judicial
philosophy or his political views I'm a
lawyer first and that's the perspective
I'm going to try to give you oh and one
last thing this is Stella the legal
beagle she reads all of your comments
now I want this to be a hearty debate
but I want it to be a civil debate if
you wouldn't say it in front of Stella
please reword it so that Stella
appropriate all right so with that out
of the way let's begin so question
number one did Judge Cavanaugh commit
perjury
now perjury is a very specific crime
taken from Title 18 of the u.s. code
perjury is defined as having taken an
oath before a competent tribunal that he
will testify
truly and contrary to such oath States
or subscribes any material matter which
he does not believe to be true now
looking at a lot of the footage from the
hearing seems to me that a lot of judge
Cavanaugh's answers appeared to be
evasive and non-responsive for example
judge Cavanaugh was asked what ralphing
referred to in the context of beach week
and he defined it as referring to his
chronically weak stomach from eating
spicy food and that he can't really keep
his food down let's look at beach week
Ralph's Club biggest contributor what
does the word ralph mean in that that
probably refers to throwing up I'm known
to have a weak stomach and I always have
in fact last time I was here you asked
me about having ketchup on spaghetti I
always have had a weak stomach
Judge Cavanaugh was asked to define
devil's triangle as it appeared in his
yearbook he defined devil's triangle as
a drinking game and not any kind of
sexual act devil's triangle drinking
game has it played three glasses in a
triangle and you ever played quarters no
okay
it's a quarters game judge Cavanaugh was
also asked to define Renata alumnus as
it appears in his yearbook he explains
that that refers to being friends with a
woman who went to a neighboring high
school you mentioned I think the Renata
or Renee Renata I don't know how you
pronounce that that's the proper name of
an individual you know Renata Renata
it's spelled with an e at the end re na
te is direct okay and then after that is
the word alumnus what does the word
alumnus mean in that context I explained
that in my opening statement we she was
a great friend of ours we bunch of us
went to dances with her she hung out
with us as a group the media circus that
has been generated by this thought in
reported that it referred to sex it did
not now
given that I was once a 17 year old boy
it seems to me that a lot of these
answers are evasive at best and flat-out
wrong in the worst case stand that
of these terms simply don't jive with
the common understanding of a lot of the
way that these words would be used some
seem unrealistic but perjury requires a
very specific mens rea ax that you
knowingly state something that is false
under oath it's possible that he and his
friends had very idiosyncratic
definitions of some of these words
perhaps they were taken out of context
and on top of that it would be very
difficult to find a definitive guide on
what these words actually mean language
is always changing but I think a lot of
the problems stem from the Democratic
senators failing to pin judge Cavanaugh
down to an actual definition if you were
to think of this hearing like a
deposition the point is not necessarily
to argue or get a Perry Mason like
admission but to lock down the witness
into a specific story and a specific
definition you lock them down so they
can't back out and you can go down the
rabbit hole to show how ridiculous it is
now normally you don't ask the witness
questions you don't know the answer to
but if you know that the answers are
going to be fairly ridiculous then you
want the witness to explain all of the
repercussions that come from the
idiosyncratic or ridiculous view that
they're taking and so you want to take
them down that road and take it to an
extreme to show how ridiculous it's seen
here a lot of the Democratic senators
failed to ask follow-up questions that
would have pinned down judge Cavanaugh
for example when he refers to the
Devil's Triangle as a drinking game you
could really pin him down to show how
ridiculous that is you could say that
it's your testimony that the Devil's
Triangle is a drinking game correct you
got a yes answer it's your testimony
that the devil's triangle does not refer
to a sexual act of some kind
he'll probably answer no it's your
testimony that the devil's triangle does
not refer to a sexual act with one woman
and two men he'll probably answer no
again the Senators could have followed
up about his weak stomach they could
have asked if he throws up every time he
has spicy food they could have asked
when was the last time he had Indian
food when was the last time he had
Mexican food Cajun food and just go down
the line and granted they might not
be able to get him to admit that maybe
he has spicy food more often than he
lets on and maybe he doesn't bomb it
every time he has it and that the
vomiting probably relates to drinking
more than it does to having
quote-unquote weak stomach but what they
can do is lay the foundation to catch
him in falsehoods later on that's one of
the big issues with this particular
hearing is that a lot of the senators
were trying to argue at the same time
they were trying to ask questions and as
any trial lawyer will tell you you
cannot argue at the same time you're
asking questions those are two separate
functions that need to be separated so
the Democratic senators should have done
a better job of separating the
cross-examinations
from the arguments so you do a better
job of laying the foundation for
catching judge Kavanagh in outright
falsehoods as in court one's character
for telling the truth on the stand is
almost always relevant and if you lay
the foundation just getting out facts
that don't seem reasonable then perhaps
after the hearing is finished you can go
do some investigations and find evidence
that contradicts what Judge Cavanaugh
stated on the stand and I suspect if
they had asked better follow-up
questions they would have been able to
do that and if we're thinking about
these particular questions as a
cross-examination like what would happen
in trial a lot of the questioners
allowed the witness to evade the
question they fell for the witness's
obfuscation and abandon their original
question and as any litigator will tell
you if you don't get an answer to the
question that you asked you asked that
exact question again and you ask that
exact question until you get the answer
that you're looking for so for example
when judge Cavanaugh was asked would you
want Marc judge to testify on your
behalf the senator asked the same
question once but then he abandons that
question to then argue with the witness
falling for the trap of wasting his time
on argument instead of following up with
the exact question if she saying my
judge was in the room then then he
should be in the room here today would
you want him called as a witness
sir this allegation came in to the
committee I'm interested in the question
would you want him to be here as a
witness
he's already provided sworn testimony of
the committee this allegations been
hidden by the committee
it has not been investigated by the FBI
the committee has refused to allow it to
be it was dropped out of here it was
sprung it was not investigated by the
FBI and he has not been called we might
be I should have been handled in the due
course senator out there when he came in
I would I would disagree with that I've
been on this committee for 44 years
I think if the senator had asked the
same question again in the correct way I
think he would have gotten a yes or no
answer but the fact is you can't argue
in question at the same time if the
witness is non-responsive
you have to stop the testimony and make
them answer now in trial you have the
advantage of having the judge there to
force the witness to answer here of
course there is no neutral judge to
force the witness to answer you can't
object as non-responsive and get the
judge to step in and make the witness
answer and the witness here judge
Cavanaugh has every incentive to waste
as much time as possible knowing that
the Senators only have five minutes for
each person despite the witness having
every incentive to waste time there are
plenty of tactics that you can use to
get the witness to answer yes or no now
first of all you have to ask a yes or no
question this doesn't work unless you
ask very pointed questions which a lot
of the Senators failed to do but if you
are phrasing your questions correctly in
the form of a yes-or-no question and the
witness is still non-responsive here's
an example of what you can do you can
say thank you for that answer but my
question was different my question was
and then just repeat your question and
then if the witness is still
non-responsive then you escalate it you
interrupt the witness and say I'm sorry
the question that I asked was yes or no
blank and then we ask the question now
if you have more time than you can try
and get the witness on your side by
explaining that you're trying to get an
answer to your question and that the
other side will have the opportunity to
allow you to expound on your answer but
you're just asking for yes or no
question
I don't want this to seem like it should
just be an incredibly aggressive process
it sort of depends on the witness but
there are a ton of rhetorical devices
that you can use to get yes or no
responses to accurately phrased
questions and here unfortunately I don't
think a lot of the Democratic senators
had much trial experience and didn't
have a lot of the rhetorical devices in
their pocket that they should have all
right so let's think like a lawyer in
regards to this question in other words
let's try to come up with the strongest
arguments on both sides of this issue I
think the Democrats would argue that
these answers don't comport with
anyone's reasonable expectation of these
particular words and the only
explanation is that judge Kavanagh is
trying to avoid the truth in order to
get through this hearing
they don't comport with common
experience and they are not accurate
representations of these words I think
that the Republican response would be
that the Democratic senators failed to
ask good cross-examination questions
they failed to pin down the witness they
allowed the witness to evade the
questions and give the answers that he
wanted to give and failed to pin down
the witness to a particular answer that
qualifies as the legal definition of
perjury now there is a separate question
as to whether a nominee should evade
questions and obfuscate but that brings
us to our second question did judge
Cavanaugh display a judge like
temperament now any judge holds a
special position in society they are the
arbiters of our disputes theoretically
they should all be impartial they need
to be able to hear both sides and make
judgment calls that have a huge effect
on the litigants lives now justices of
the Supreme Court are appointed for life
and they hold an even higher place in
our society they literally make
life-or-death decisions sometimes so
it's not surprising that both judges and
justices are held to a very very high
standard they are supposed to be neutral
they are not supposed to take a partisan
stance they are supposed to be able to
be the neutral arbiters of our general
disputes in his opening statement judge
Cavanaugh made some very provocative
statements about the backlash being a
result of revenge
inge from the clintons this whole
two-week effort has been a calculated
and orchestrated political hit fueled
with a parent pent-up anger about
President Trump and the 2016 election
fear that has been unfairly stoked about
my judicial record revenge on behalf of
the Clintons and millions of dollars in
money from outside left-wing opposition
groups this is a circus judge Cavanaugh
also got into a sparring match with
senator Klobuchar when she asked about
past drinking I think you've probably
had beer center and and so you're saying
there's never been a case where you
drink so much that you didn't remember
what happened the night before or part
of what happened that's you're asking
about yeah blackout I don't know have
you could you answer the question judge
I just so you that's not happened is
that your answer
yeah and I'm curious if you have I have
no drinking problem nor do i okay thank
you and judge Kavanagh also got into
some sparring matches with other
senators about some pointed questions
did the word Ralph you used your
question if you're gonna relate to
alcohol I like her for that I like beer
I don't know if you'd okay like beer
senator and what do you like to direct
one is Senator what do you I judge have
you so let's think like a lawyer I think
the Democrats would probably argue that
this shows a character for not being
impartial for taking partisan stances
and that his hotheadedness shows that he
doesn't have the temperament to be a
Supreme Court justice who we hold to a
very very high standard not to say
anything of the allegations of sexual
assault that have given rise to this
whole hearing I think the Republicans
would probably respond that he should
not have been asked these questions in
the first place that they weren't proper
to begin with and that he is
understandably angry for being put in
this position now I think we can make
another parallel to
some trial law as a rule of evidence
generally character evidence is not
admissible at trial but the main
exception is where the accused has made
character an issue and they usually do
that by calling a bunch of witnesses to
explain how good of a person they are
and how they never could have done the
underlying crime now here judge Kavanagh
has done something similar he has
essentially said that he was not a heavy
drinker he has never blacked out
he has never used sexual slang in the
context that he's alleged and he has
never engaged in inappropriate sexual
behavior in some ways if we were to draw
a parallel to a trial this has opened
the door to test his veracity for
truthfulness and also to show whether
these superlative statements that he's
making are true or not so do you think
the judge Kavanaugh displayed a judge
like behavior let me know I leave it to
you now that takes me to issue number
three would judge Kavanaugh
if elevated to the Supreme Court prevent
an investigation into the President or
the White House now a lot of pundits
have argued that judge Kavanaugh
in particular was nominated to the
Supreme Court because he holds an
idiosyncratic view that the sitting
president cannot be indicted civilly or
criminally a lot of this stems from a
law review article that he wrote in the
Minnesota Law Review called the
separation of powers during the 44th
presidency and beyond in that Law Review
piece judge Kavanaugh argued that
Congress should pass a law that while
the president is in office he should not
be subject to civil lawsuits or to
criminal investigation or prosecution
he explained that based on his
first-hand experience in the White House
he came to believe that the job of the
president is quote far more difficult
than any other civil position in
government end quote and he also says
that the President must be able to focus
on the tasks of being president and
shouldn't be distracted by civil or
criminal trials judge Kavanagh
recognized the irony of his position
given that he started his legal career
in the independent counsel's office with
Kenneth Starr during the Clinton
impeachment investigation and he imposed
exactly the kinds of burdens that he's
saying a sitting president should not
have to deal with so let's think like a
lawyer about the
position I think the Republicans would
argue that the Supreme Court is supposed
to decide what is mandated by the
Constitution and they should not let
their individual policy preferences
guide their decision-making a Supreme
Court justice is supposed to interpret
the Constitution and not make policy by
Fiat and I think the Republicans would
argue that this Law Review piece is
advocating that Congress pass a law and
not that there is a constitutional
mandate for this particular policy
position and in fact judge Cavanaugh has
made statements to that effect that he
recognizes his policy preference is not
mentioned in the Constitution and may
contradict what's in the Constitution
and therefore his stance as a sitting
justice on the Supreme Court is not
informed by this particular Law Review
article or the policies that he
advocated I think the Democrats would
argue that while that's nice in theory
isn't it funny how often policy
preferences line up with one's own
personal theory of what the Constitution
mandates what it says and what needs to
be interpreted as a result of the
Constitution upon being elevated to the
Supreme Court they suddenly find a
textual reason for their particular
policy preference the bottom line is I
don't think we know for certain which
way judge Kavanaugh would rule if he was
elevated to the Supreme Court
you can argue both ways based on his
prior statements so that takes us to
question number four would dr. Christine
Blasi Ford's allegations of sexual
assault hold up in court and otherwise
could they lead to judge Kavanaugh being
convicted of sexual assault now criminal
law has the highest burden under the law
the prosecution in other words the
people making the claim must prove their
case beyond a reasonable doubt
now the accused technically has no
burden at all the prosecution doesn't
meet their burden then the defendant
should not have to make any showing in
order to avoid conviction so to decide
if the allegations would hold up in
court we need to look at the evidence
now there is one statement that I see
coming up in the news a lot that I think
we should talk about a lot of pundits
have argued that there is no evidence of
sexual assault
one of my biggest pet peeves as a lawyer
is when people will refer to
he said she said scenario and refer to
it as if there is no evidence even if
there is only he said she said with no
physical evidence there is in fact
evidence in the form of testimony
imagine if you had a police officer who
testified that she saw a bank robber
robbed a bank the bank robber could deny
that and technically that is a he-said
she-said scenario but I bet you would
probably think the first-hand testimony
of the police officer was pretty strong
evidence and in fact often you get
people talking about circumstantial
versus direct evidence and this is
another one of my big pet peeves
circumstantial evidence is evidence that
relies on an inference in order to
connect it to a conclusion of fact for
example DNA evidence at the scene of a
crime by contrast direct evidence
supports the truth of an assertion
directly without the need for additional
evidence or inference so I don't mean to
imply that circumstantial evidences ever
inherently bad or week often
circumstantial evidence is the strongest
evidence that there is but in this
particular case we happen to have direct
evidence we have dr. Christine Blasi
Ford's testimony now you may believe her
testimony or you may not believe her
testimony but if this were a court of
law that would still qualify as
particular evidence it would be direct
evidence in the form of her particular
first-hand testimony of what happened to
her in 1983
so as a threshold matter there is
evidence there is evidence on the side
of dr. Christine Blasi Ford in the form
of her testimony and there is evidence
on the side of Judge cabinet on the form
of his direct testimony and that is
separate from the question of whether
dr. Fords testimony would meet the
burden of beyond a reasonable doubt I
don't know how a jury would come out on
this question but as we discussed with
perjury I'm not sure that whether
something meets the technical legal
definition and the hurdle of beyond a
reasonable doubt is really beside the
point or not so that brings me to
question number five should Judge
Cavanaugh have requested an
investigation during the hearing the
Democratic senators asked a lot of
questions of Judge Kavanaugh asking if
he would be in favor of a further FB
I investigation into his conduct and
what dr. Ford alleges happened to her so
I'm gonna ask you one last time are you
willing to ask the White House to
authorize the FBI to investigate the
claims that have been made against you
well I'll do whatever the committee
wants of course and I've heard you say
that but a witness you asked I've not
heard you answer a very specific
question that's been asked which is are
you willing to ask the White House to
conduct an investigation by the FBI to
get to whatever you believe is the
bottom of the allegations that have been
levied against you and whether he should
have requested an FBI investigation
probably depends on your definition of
should as an attorney I can't imagine a
situation where I would counsel a client
to ask for a further investigation of
that client speaking as an attorney it's
usually not a good idea to encourage an
investigation into your client and just
because you don't have anything to hide
doesn't mean you have anything you
actively want to share but that
particularly GLE advice would have no
bearing in this particular case as to
whether calling for an investigation
would be a good PR move or whether it is
the morally right thing to do I'll leave
that to the moral philosophers because
this is not a legal question this is a
political ethical and moral question and
in general you don't want to ask your
lawyer for a philosophical advice so do
you agree leave your objections in the
comments and let me know what other
pressing legal issues I should cover
next and as always I'll see you in court